ouais si jean paul gaultier
ok
merci d'être avec nous merci d'être avec
nous puisque demain c'est la collection
homme et vous êtes ici malgré tout
malgré tes adieux man ray des larmes
dates et les chemins et jean paul
gaultier
vous remarquerez le m messieurs a eu la
délicatesse de s'habiller en thierry
ardisson c'est sympa merci sont passés
en chine
je vous demande de vous arrêter après ça
fait un peu mégalo quand même jean paul
bonsoir en tous les cas merci d'être là
semaine cruciale effectivement pour la
mode avec l'art est effectivement de la
maison saint laurent semaine des défilés
dans le vôtre que j'ai eu la chance de
voir dimanche dernier alors pierre bergé
a dit en parlant de vous c'est le plus
grand depuis saint laurent et on a
longtemps cru d'ailleurs que vous seriez
le successeur d'yves saint laurent mais
maintenant vous et votre petite affaire
à vous voilà devenu un petit chez soi
comme jean-paul ya encore 65% de sa
maison donc celui qui décide 35% chez
hermès c'est parfait vous êtes bien
démerdé alors vous étiez au dernier
défilé de saint laurent avec bourse dé
rendre hommage ce maître yves saint
laurent et il y avait quand même ce qui
est incroyable ça c'est très très
typique de l'exception française
il y avait des grands écrans dehors et
puis des gens mille personnes qui ont
applaudi à la fin du défilé jusqu'à
l'incroyable salon c'est génial on va
faire partager à des tas de gens qui
n'étaient pas dans la salle ça s'est
très très bien
ouais et c'est rare en plus en plus cité
un moment quand même exceptionnel quoi
loi de voir une rétrospective comme ça
de vêtements qui ont daté de 1960
j'ai pas une avait en 61,3 la première
traduction pratiquement way pratiquement
alors karl lagerfeld a déclaré dimanche
dans le journal du dimanche
c'est pas parce que yves saint laurent
raccroche que la haute couture est morte
parce que je crois que c'est que c'est
vrai qu'avec saint orens comment une
époque de la haute couture est morte
parce que lui représente quand même tout
le passé de la couture avec janet
dior les valencians alors votre votre
haute couture et l équilibre financier
pratiquement maintenant où elle presque
on va dire que c'est récupéré 70
millions par an quand ma main je vais
dépenser beaucoup plus bien alors
dimanche dernier donc j'ai vu le défilé
couture femme alors très people iv
madonna elle est un peu petit quand même
allée ouest
son mari un petit anagramme est bien
proportionné suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous alors madonna elle est venue
le samedi en jet de londres en jet privé
l ex copine qui s'appelle green est oui
net mais pas trop sans qu'elle vient
avec sa copine gwyneth elle passe la
nuit au crillon et le lendemain qu'est
ce qu'elle va au défilé de jean paul
c'est sympa quand même tu vois la vie
comme fait comme ça en plus je l'étalé
après déjeuner au bazar tous les deux à
que tous les deux non il y avait
d'autres personnes en mer et c'est
souvent comme ça parce que ça il faut
savoir quand même jean paul c'est que ne
dit pas comment tu sais ça parce que je
veux c'est vous dites c'est la seule
femme avec laquelle j'aurais pu faire
l'amour et oui c'est un bon choix non à
part mais aucune française ne te fait
franchir le pas là je sais pas mais elle
n'est pas non plus américaine à les
mélanger à l'étal est agréable à l'oeil
quand clavier comme ça
alors vous l'avez demandé jean paul
trois fois en mariage à chaque fois l'a
refusée poliment très poliment
ah ouais voilà ça n'a jamais marché
entre lampaul et madonna et maintenant
elle est mariée
ben oui passe au scanner costa il porte
une jupe ceci dit la chevy gauthier
voilà voilà alors donc c'était très
people il est madonna y avait bertrand
delanoë le maire de paris que je salue
ici bertrand tels que c'est bertrand
sachant qu'hier il ya madame pompidou ça
c'est incroyable
donc c'est assez fou parce qu'elles
continuent à ferrals ça plein
d'activités
or les mannequins d'annoncés très classe
chez gaultier yves et naomi campbell y
avait une haie de la fressange carla
bruni duels et à san jose une vieille
copine à nous 1
et puis vous êtes pas faire maintenant
c'est un peu la mode d'éviter les top
modèles stars sur les podiums ou pas du
tout avait toujours cette fidélité comme
des stars et des passants cergy toujours
pris à la fois bon certaine les stars
quand elle me convenait enfin quand elle
vous convenez ces terres qu'elle allait
bien avec mes vêtements ou alors des
mannequins qui était pas du tout
mannequin j'avais fait défilé jean-paul
à l'époque edwige live voilà hilal 80
tonnes que des pas de première jeunesse
loana steevy enfin voila vous le récent
rachat duraient depuis la mi mai et donc
j'ai eu un mannequin qui avait 75 ans
qui était génial une femme vraiment
qu'ils avaient toute sa vie rêvé d'être
mannequin je devais dans les années 30
elle devait rêver de même qu'un et ses
parents elle avait interdit la réaliser
son rêve à 75 ans eh bien non elle était
super beau si c'est ça c'est que c'est
pas du tout alors on peut avoir un âge
certain
c'est vous avez eu des idées formidables
par jean kiffer des robes maintenant tu
sais que des cravates ont des cravates
que vous avez dû voir un jour dans une
droguerie en province parce que c'est
des cravates un sens et des cravates des
années car en a partout comme cette
grande friperie ou des antiquaires ccd
cravate qui sont assemblés bord à bord
et ça fait des robes les plus les deux
violoncelles aussi c'est très très beau
c'est à dire cold et il savait que je
suis sûr que c'est magnifique ça aurait
pu penser un petit peu quand même un
modèle qui a déjà été décomptés comme ça
c'était merida ce qui pourrait être dans
un film bon mais là non c'est simplement
car il y avait déjà un décolleté mais
qui était retenu par une chaîne le mien
n'était pas retenue
celle par les fesses de carla bruni les
herbes il ya une robe qui est génial
c'est à dire complètement comme un peu
comme marilyn quoi faire complètement
relevé devant comme étant un trou de
vent comme exactement c'est exactement
l'idée derrière ce une robe normal comme
si le mans s'est relevé